isn't it weird how some people who are
so talented leave Saturday Night Live
and nothing happens like there's just
nowhere for them to go to channel that
kind of funny it is there is the thing
that I you know I think the hardest
skill in the world is to have the skill
where you succeed at SNL because you
need so many different things right and
and sometimes there yeah that's almost
like your talent is too big to fit
anywhere like late 90s yes Chris Kattan
was a killing it [ __ ] superstar uh
when he would do the dancing segment you
know where did they go to the club to
pick up girls yes I mean that's that's
physical comedy at its best he was uh
yeah he was unparalleled and I think
that there's a couple people that I
don't quite feel like get there do from
that time and Sheri Oteri is the other
one Sheri Oteri was amazing and I think
people I don't know why there's this
weird blindspot to what they were doing
cuz that was a you know mid-90s SNL had
this really bumpy time and then well
that's only because the critics I think
yeah gave it a hard time I don't was it
ratings wise to I don't know actually
getting again I'm in college at the time
but then I remember there was all of a
sudden these new people and you know
obviously Will Ferrell gets all the
credit in the world as he deserves and
Molly I feel like is properly remembered
as being great Pollyanna and well yeah
that when she would throw her body
physically across the room into a roof
of chairs and first of all I'm surprised
she doesn't have like major issues with
her body in terms of pain it was I mean
that is really I take a gold stand when
we talk about like physical comedy and
it was also like really well-written and
I want to just say that it was but uh
when you look at what will and Molly and
sharing and Chris were doing I mean that
was it was a good group it was really a
fun fun show I'm curious obviously what
Eddie Murphy does when he goes and guest
hosts I know I can't wait I cannot wait
I that's most
I mean is there can you remember a time
you've been that excited for someone to
host maybe every time they say like
Steve Martin will do it right but you
know that hasn't happened in a while Jim
Carrey I think about like seven or eight
years ago came back and hosted and that
was I mean for us that was such a big
deal cuz again he I think like Eddie you
know he was this sketch actor that we
all kind of grew up on but Eddie's gonna
be amazing well how crazy is that that
Jim Carrey audition for Saturday Night
Live and didn't get in didn't get in I
wonder if Loren kicks himself in the
head that he didn't sign
pick the ones that get away I think
Lauren also likes that that's part of
the like mystique of SNL is that
sometimes they got it wrong yeah you
know what I mean like that uh I just
looked somebody found the sheet of when
I auditioned I think Kevin Hart
auditioned the year I odd oh really
the crane he didn't game's Kevin Hart